Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur, ich bin die Diastaben der Arschin auf der Station und würde gerne das als Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das Ordnung für Sie? Ja.
Okay, so erst werden ein paar Fragen Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Patricia Sommerfeld.
Patricia Sommerfeld.
Frau Sommerfeld, könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Patricia bestabiert sich P-A-T-R-C-I-A, Patricia.
Und Sommerfeld S-O-M-E-R-F-E-L-D, Sommerfeld.
Sommerfeld, okay, Sommerfeld.
Danke schön Frau Sommerfeld, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. Mai 1985.
Okay, wissen Sie wie groß Sie sind?
1,72 m.
63 kg.
Wie heiß sind Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Dr. Schmidt.
Und mit D oder T?
DT am Ende, DT Schmidt.
Danke schön für diese Informationen.
Und was für Sie heute sonst?
Ich habe ungefähr seit 24 Stunden starke Übelkeit und auch starke Erbrechen.
Mindestens fünfmal habe ich in den letzten Stunden erbrochen.
Ich habe dazu auch Bauchschmerzen im ganzen Bauch.
Das war nicht so sehr stark, aber das ist nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich da nicht wohl.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit einem Tag, 24 Stunden.
Ein Tag, okay.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Mit Märzen sind sie eher so krampfartig.
Krampfartig.
Und eigentlich tut der ganze Bauch jetzt weh.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen in Gärntwochen aus?
Nein.
Okay.
Bis Tag sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von ein bis zehn.
Wobei ein sehr lafter, sehr starker Schmerz entspricht.
Vier bis fünf.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, kann ich aushalten.
Okay.
Und Sie haben Übelkeit und Erbrochen.
Wie sagt Ihr, dass Erbrochen aus?
Das war so wässrig schleimig.
Okay.
Denken Sie, dass es einen Ausdöse für diese Beschwerden haben Sie eine ungewöhnlich Essen gegessen?
Also ich war am Tag vorher mit meinem Mann auf einer Feier.
Und da wurde einiges gegrillt.
Es gab Hühnerfleisch, es gab Lampfleisch, es gab Salate.
Ich habe Hühnerfleisch gegessen und auch Nudelsalat.
Und mein Mann, der hat jetzt seit zwei, drei Stunden Beschwerden.
Bauchschmerzen und hat sich auch schon einmal erbrochen.
Der ist später angefangen.
Ich habe das seit einem Tag.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Sind die Schmerzen guter für mich?
Oder nein?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Durchfall?
Ja, das habe ich auch.
Das ist eigentlich zusammen mit dem Erbrechen gekommen.
Ich habe Durchfall mindestens jetzt in den letzten Stunden acht Mal.
Und ja, das schwächt mich schon.
Okay.
Wir sind Farbe und Konsistenz.
Das Stuss haben Sie...
Was ist Konsistenz?
Was heißt Konsistenz?
Sie haben fest oder wassierig?
Ach so.
Nein, das ist so wässrig, schleimig.
Sehr wässrig.
Haben Sie im Blut das Stuhl?
Nein, kein Blutstuhl.
Okay.
Hat das Stuhl unangenehm?
Geruch auch?
Ja, es riecht nicht angenehm.
Es riecht sehr extrem, etwas stark.
Okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit einem Tag nicht gut.
Seitdem ich das jetzt habe, habe ich keinen Hunger, keinen Appetit.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber auch?
Ja, ich habe etwas...
Ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, ich habe Fieber und dann habe ich gemessen.
Hier bist du gerade vor einer Stunde und da hatte ich 38.
Das ist ungewöhnlich für mich. Normalerweise habe ich selten Fieber.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost?
Schüttelfrost nicht, aber ich muss stark schwitzen.
Stark schwitzen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Haben Sie mehr Durst als gewöhnlich?
Ja, ich habe jetzt mehr Durst, weil ich glaube, ich habe jetzt auch durch das Erbrochen erbrechen
und durch den Durchfall habe ich viel Flüssigkeit verloren.
Haben Sie Probleme auch Wasser lassen?
Nein, das Wasser lassen ist in Ordnung. Das geht.
Der Urin ist etwas dunkel, aber ich kann auch wenig Wasser lassen,
weil ich glaube, ich habe so viel ausgebrochen und so viel durchwahl verloren.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Frau Sommerfeldt, ist bei Ihnen irgendeine Krönchenerkrankung bekannt?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe seit ungefähr 20 Jahren eine chronische Schildrösenentzündung.
Zu Anfang war da auch eine Unterfunktion in den ersten Monaten.
Und dann habe ich aber Medikamente bekommen und muss ich jetzt immer noch nehmen, eine Tablette immer morgens.
Und jetzt ist aber die Schildrösenfunktion in Ordnung, aber ich muss das Medikament weiternehmen.
Okay.
Kennen Sie die Name des Medikament?
Ja, das Medikament heißt L-Tyroxin.
L-Tyroxin.
Welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Dahinter steht 50.
50.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette, eine halbe Stunde vor dem Frühstück.
Ja, okay.
Noch etwas?
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente, aber ich habe noch seit fünf Jahren eine Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Fruchtzucker.
Ja, aber seitdem ich das weiß und mich dementsprechend nach meiner Ernährung danach richte, habe ich dann kaum mehr Beschwerden.
Da hatte ich früher häufig Bauchschmerzen auch und Bläuren und so, aber das ist dann besser geworden.
Bestimmte Nahrungsmittel vermeide ich einfach, die sehr stark Fruchtzucker enthalten.
Das geht ganz gut.
Okay.
Ja, dann hatte ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall mit so Ischias-Beschwerden ins rechte Bein.
Das wurde dann behandelt mit Spritzen und mit Krankengymnastik.
Das ist dann wieder ganz gut geworden.
Ich muss mich aber aufpassen, wie ich mich bücke und hebe und bewege.
Da muss ich sehr vorsichtig sein.
Jetzt haben Sie keine Probleme?
Nein, ich habe zurzeit keine Probleme.
Okay, würde Sie schon mal operieren?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich zehn Jahre alt, da wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Und im Alter von 22 Jahren, da hatte ich einen Autounfall und da war mein linker Oberschenkel gebrochen.
Da wurde auch eine Operation gemacht, da wurde ein Nagel eingeführt in den Oberschenkelknochen.
Okay, ich verstehe, ich tut mir sehr leid.
Dann hatte ich noch eine Operation.
Im Alter von 32 Jahren hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt gebohrt.
Kaiserschnitten.
Ja, das war im Alter von 32 Jahren, also vor acht Jahren war das.
Okay, rauen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich so zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
zwei Glas Wein.
Okay.
Und hätten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Greifen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ach, ich mache etwas Yoga.
Aber sonst, ich habe Schichtdienst in meiner Arbeit.
Da ist das manchmal schwierig mit irgendwie in einen Sportverein zu gehen.
Ich mache nur noch Yoga und versuche etwas zu wandern, so mich zu bewegen.
Aber es könnte besser sein.
Ja.
Okay, schreiben Sie Sport einmal in Pro Woche?
Ja, ich mache so zwei Mal die Woche zu machen.
Einmal zu Hause und einmal in einer Gruppe.
Okay.
Okay, gibt es in Ihrer Familie krönliche Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit oder Wulutowdruck?
Ja, mein Vater.
Mein Vater ist 68 Jahre alt.
Er hat Alterszucker und er hat hohen Blutdruck schon seit einigen Jahren.
Aber was er für Medikamente nimmt, kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Die Mutter, die ist 66 Jahre alt, die hatte vor zwei Jahren,
wurde bei ihr Dickdarmkrebs festgestellt.
Okay, ich bin jetzt eine.
Er wurde sie operiert und hat seitdem einen künstlichen Ausgang, künstlichen Darmausgang.
Okay.
Aber sie kommt damit ganz gut zurecht.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 42 Jahre alt.
Der ist gesund.
Mir ist jetzt aber noch etwas eingefallen.
Mir, ich wurde vor zwei Jahren operiert an der rechten Schulter.
Und zwar wurde da schwarzer Hautkrebs festgestellt.
Schwarzer Hautkrebs, ja.
Und operiert in der Hautklinik.
Bin dann noch in Kontrolle, muss da regelmäßig zu Kontrollen hin.
Aber bisher ist das in Ordnung.
Bisher sind die Ärzte zufrieden.
Okay.
Was machen Sie?
Ich bin Busfahrerin.
Busfahrerin.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und Sie sind weihreihertet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter.
Vor acht Jahren ist die ja geboren worden, bei der Kaiserschnittgeburt.
Wir wohnen zusammen in einer Wohnung.
Mein Mann und ich mit der Tochter.
Sie haben Forschungs- und Verträglichkeit.
Aber haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Allergie.
Sind Sie vorstandig gebt?
Ja, ich werde immer einmal im Jahr,
muss ich zu Betriebsarzt in der Firma,
wo ich arbeite, in den Brustbetrieben.
Da werde ich immer untersuchen, mit den Impfungen.
Sonst schaut auch meine Hausärzte immer nach.
Und sie sagt, im Augenblick bin ich genügend geimpft.
Ich werde als Busfahrerin auch regelmäßig auf Grippe geimpft,
weil ich so viel Kontakt habe mit Menschen.
Okay.
War es Ihnen in Lesse seit im Ausland?
Ja, wir waren in Thailand.
Thailand.
Wir waren acht Wochen,
waren wir für zwei Wochen in Thailand,
haben einen Badenurlaub gemacht.
Da hatte ich zwei Tage lang auch eine Magen-Damm-Infektion.
Aber die ist dann gut ausgeheilt.
Danach hatte ich auch keine Beschwerden.
Okay.
Haben Sie regelmäßig Ihre Periode?
Ja, die habe ich regelmäßig.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zu Ihrem Fraunorst?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zu der Gynäkologin.
Da gehe ich einmal im Jahr hin.
Und da war bisher nichts auffälliges.
Die ist zufrieden.
Könnten Sie schwänger sein?
Ich glaube nicht.
Mein Mann ist sterilisiert.
Okay.
Danke schon für diese informativen Fraunorfälle.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas für uns zufügen?
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann ich haben?
Was kann das sein?
Weil so schlecht ist es mehr schon lange nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Fraunorfälle, ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Meine Verda ist auf Sie haben eine...
Darme Infektion.
Ja, Narungsgifting kann sein.
Aber um eine ein-to-üttige Diagnose zu stellen,
müssen wir ein paar Unterrichtungen dafür führen.
Deshalb möchte ich zuerst die körperlichen Unterrichtungen dann
bultabnehmen und weitere Unterrichtungen dafür führen.
Dann ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorlegen,
kann ich Ihnen etwas Genares sagen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit.
In der Prüfung haben Sie mehr Zeit demnächst.
Da haben Sie 20 Minuten Zeit.
Versuchen Sie jetzt, die Patienten Sprache, die Begriffe möglichst in die
Fachsprache zu übersetzen, die Portionen, die Begriffe wie
Übelkeit, Erbrechen usw.
Durchfall.
Wenn die Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen haben oder
Ergänzungen haben, können Sie gerne jetzt fragen.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Ja, bitte.
Frau Sommerfeld, waren Sie am Feiern richtig?
Nein, Feier. Es war eine Geburtstagsfeier.
Okay, haben Sie etwas gehört, dass es andere Leute auf der Feier
mit ähnlichen Beschwerden gibt?
Also bisher habe ich mich noch nicht erkundigt, aber mein Mann hat
ja auch jetzt mit so Beschwerden angefangen.
Ja, und der war auch auf der Feier.
Aber wir wollen uns noch erkundigen auch bei anderen, die dort
waren auf der Feier, ob es vielleicht ähnlich, manchen ähnlich geht.
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie oft leiden Sie letztes Jahr am Durchfall?
Ich habe eigentlich vorher in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
keinen großen Durchfall gehabt, bis auf die 2 Tage in Thailand,
wo ich in Thailand war.
Da hatte ich 2 Tage auch Durchfall, aber danach war das
wieder gut.
Und vorher hatte ich keinen großen Durchfall mehr, seitdem ich das
mit der Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit ernähre.
Ich mich dementsprechend, dass ich der Fruchtzuckerhaltige
Sachen vermeide.
Seitdem geht es mir ein.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte.
Ist Ihnen trockene Haut aufgefallen?
Trockene Haut? Nein, nicht so direkt.
Aber ich habe sicherlich in den letzten Stunden
relativ wenig getrunken, weil ich habe aber auch Flüssigkeit
verloren durch Erbrechen und Durchfall.
Aber ich habe glaube ich die Flüssigkeit bisher nicht ausgeglichen.
Das kann sein, dass ich etwas ausgetrocknet bin.
Wissen Sie seit gestern, wie viele Liter haben Sie getrunken?
Das gestern?
Nicht so viel, weil mir ja immer übel ist.
Da konnte ich vielleicht 1 Liter oder 2 Liter.
Okay, das ist sehr wenig.
Ist Ihnen gelbliche Haut aufgefallen?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein.
Danke.
Herr, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz seit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Okay, die Patientin heißt Patricia Sommerfeld.
Sie ist 40 Jahre alt, ein Meter 72 groß und wiegt 83 kg.
63 kg.
63.
Frau Sommerfeld startet sich heute bei uns wegen seit einem Tag
starker Neusea, 5-mal Erbre, 5-mal Emesis und die Füße
Abdominalschmerzen vor.
Der Patient berichtet über auf Fieber 38,3 Grad
und Diary, Wasserik- und Schleimungdiary
und Hyperhydrosa.
Die Erbrecher sind von der Erbrecher- und Schleimungdiary
bis zum 4-mal-Ein-Fünffensein, der 6-mal-Skala.
Die 5-mal-Ein-Skala sind von der Erbrecher- und Schleimungdiary
bis zum 4-mal-Ein-Skala.
Die Erbrecher sind von der Erbrecher- und Schleimungdiary
An für Erkrankungen, 10% leidet seit 1,2 Jahren
an Troiditis,
die Patienten.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig 5-50 mg
und die Dosierung ist Mikrogramm.
Sie haben eine Spritzen- und Krankengymnastik behandelt.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, vor 2 Jahren hatte sie einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Man kann sagen einen lumbalen Diskusprolaps.
Eventuell Prolaps.
Ob es wirklich ein Bandscheibenvorfall war oder nur eine Protusion,
weiß ich nicht.
Also lumbale Diskusprolaps.
Und es wurde vor 2 Jahren wie behandelt, operativ oder konservativ?
Konservative.
Der Patient wurde konservativ behandelt.
Der Patient wurde konservativ behandelt mit Spritzen und Krankengymnastik.
Der Patient hat eine Malinmelanombekannt.
Wann war das?
Vor 2 Jahren.
Und wo?
Wissen Sie noch, wo das war?
Ja, in Rehterschulter.
Rechtes Kapu-La-Bereich.
Mehr hat die Patientin nicht gesagt.
Sie hat eine Operation für diese Malinmelanombe.
Sie geht nur Kontrolle.
Sie befindet sich noch in der Nachsorge, die ja in der Regel 5 Jahre ist.
Sie ist in der Nachsorge, der amatologische Kontrolle.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten bei der Patientin in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja.
Sein Vater leidet an Diabetes mele tystib 2 und Arterie per Tony.
Seine Mutter hat Kolonkarsinom.
Sie hat vor 2 Jahren eine Operation gehalten.
Vor 2 Jahren wurde ein Kolonkarsinom operiert.
Sie hat jetzt eine Kolostomie.
Kolostomie, Anuspräter, wie auch immer.
Kolostomie ist korrekt.
Sie hat eine gesunde Bruder.
Die Patientin hat sonst Risikofaktoren.
Nikotin, Alkohol.
Sie trinkt 2-3 Glasweine pro Woche.
Sie macht Yoga 3-mal pro Woche.
Sie wandert.
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Sie ist Busfahrerin.
Da hat sie einen Beruf, wo sie viel Auto fährt, aber sich wenig bewegt.
Sie muss immer sitzen.
Ja, immer sitzen.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie hat eine Kinder.
Sie hat keine Allergie.
Sie ist vollständig.
Sie war für 2 Wochen in Thailand.
Sie hatte Probleme in Thailand.
Sie haben eine Magen-Darm-Infektion für 2 Tage.
Sie hat keine Probleme.
War die Patientin in Malaria gebeten?
Ich habe diese Fragen nicht gestellt.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, sie kontrolliert regelmäßig.
Sie hat alle Notwendige infunkten gehabt.
Malaria ist in der Probung geimpft.
Aber bei Reisen werden dann als Profilaxetabletten genannt.
Malarone, Atovakone.
Das müsste man vielleicht noch fragen.
Waren Sie in einem Malaria-Gebiet, haben Sie Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben?
Weil wir wissen, dass eine Malaria nach einem Aufenthalt auftreben kann.
Man sollte diese Leitbreite im Hinterkopf behalten
und eventuell im Labor auf einen dicken Tropfen machen.
Sie sollten eine Malaria ausschließen.
Gut, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Damen, die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am Ehesten ein Gastroenteritis hin.
Auf Gastroenteritis hin.
Als die finanziellen Diagnosen kommen, chronische Erkrankungen oder Divertikulitis, Reisdarm-Sendrum
oder Malaria.
Malaria würde ich zumindest bei der Reise anamnise, zumindest differenzial diagnostisch dran denken.
Denken, ja.
Aber ich glaube ganz vorrangig besteht der Verdacht auf eine akute Gastroenteritis.
Wahrscheinlich aufgrund einer, vielleicht ist, war das Hühnerfleisch nicht gut durchgegart.
Aber es gibt ja den berühmten Keim, zumindest in Deutschland, Campylobacca, je Juni,
der häufig leider im Hühnerfleisch ist.
Und wenn das Fleisch nicht gut durchgegart wird, dann kann dieser Keim Probleme bereiten.
Campylobacca ist ein meldepflichtiger Keim, der muss dem Gesundheitsamt gemeldet werden.
Aber wenn er im Labor diagnostiziert wird durch die Stuhlprobe,
dann muss das Labor das auch melden ans Gesundheitsamt.
Wahrscheinlich handelt es sich so etwas um so etwas.
In Deutschland zumindest ist das häufig der Fall nach solchen Salaten oder eben Hühnerfleisch.
Das ist das Problem, so lecker Hühnerfleisch ist.
Aber man muss es gut durchgaren und mit Campylobacca nicht mehr arbeiten kann.
Es spricht dafür, der Ehemann hat jetzt auch Probleme.
Und wahrscheinlich wird es sein, wenn die Menschen sich erkundigen bei der Gesellschaft,
die dort auch in der Feier war, dass vielleicht einige andere auch diese Beschwerden haben.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht, sehr systematisch und ruhig.
Verwechseln Sie einfach nicht, wenn da steht, als Kind blind nahm,
dass Sie dann sagen, tonsi-lectomie, das war nur ein Versehen, ist mir klar.
Aber nur, dass Sie da an so etwas denken.
Aber sonst haben Sie die Begriffe alle sehr gut übersetzt.
Und Sie können die Begriffe und kennen die Begriffe, auch die Diagnosen,
der Autoimmuntyrioditis, Sie haben gesagt, vermutlich ist ja auch so Hashimoto.
Das ist, wenn es das häufigste.
Wenn eine chronische Tyrioiditis diagnostiziert wird,
ist es meistens diese Hashimoto-Tyrioditis.
Ja, Fruchtose-Unverträglichkeit, nicht verwechseln mit Laktose.
Ja, ja.
Fruchtzucker, Laktose der Milchzucker, der Discus-Prolaps,
der Lumbale Discus-Prolaps.
Wir wissen nicht genau, welches Segment betroffen war.
Das könnten Sie eventuell während der Untersuchung noch mal fragen,
wo denn da die Beschwerden waren.
Aber ja, alles gut.
Das Malignemelanom haben Sie erwähnt.
Die Begriffe wie Diabetes-Meditus Typ 2,
Atelierdehypertonie, Coulomcatsinom, Kulostomie.
Ja, alles gut, alles in Ordnung.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl für Ihre Prüfung am Samstag.
Vor der Erdbeerkammer in Stuttgart.
Ja.
Dann hoffe ich, dass Sie die notwendigen Bescheinigungen
demnächst alle zusammen haben, dass Sie auch arbeiten können.
Dankeschön.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen alles Gute.
Und bedanke mich auch bei der Gruppe für die Mitarbeit.
Sagen Sie bitte, Herr Moderator.